[Music]
I want to be outrageous I think that the
problem is is that when you've lost your
ability to dream when you're told what
you can't do you know something bad
happens uh nobody's searching for a
fraction for pi because you've been told
it's not possible to find one so that's
good you don't waste your lives but when
somebody tells you look up at the night
sky try to imagine all the amazing
things and you're never getting there
it's incredibly frustrating I don't
understand
why we aren't taking these things more
seriously look there are topological and
geometric ways of considering worm holes
and you have to get the matter right in
the pressur so that the thing doesn't
close up and maybe it's impossible
whatever why are you wasting your time
on a wormhole what is it with all of you
that you want to stay responsible and in
the scientific einsteinian Paradigm and
yet clearly you've got science fiction
Hearts you're pining after Jodie Foster
you're you're forcing Kip for Kip Thorn
and car a to be somewhat mathematically
realistic when Consulting to these films
at some level get out of Einstein's
prison and explore the idea of the
theory Beyond Einstein that renders
Einstein effective don't stay in the
prison and daydream about Freedom the
door is open it's yours to leave
Einstein theory is incredibly well
tested in the solar system um to it's
being tested by looking at the way
particles move or planets move
satellites move but far more important a
kip Thorn that was just mentioned won
the Nobel Prize for his incredible work
in building these gravitational wave
detectors and Einstein's theory
predicted gravitational wave detectors
that predicted the black holes would
exist that they would Circle each other
they would give off gravitational waves
all of that has been proven to be true
in the last three or four years which is
why Kip Thorn was awarded the Nobel
Prime so let's stick with a theory which
is incredibly well tested until there's
a reason to say it is not the way things
are so I just want to take a poll does
anyone want to see three people agree
for a
debate all right in that case even
though we're old friends George George
George the situation is different than
you say it used to be we got to have fun
girdle had you could put together a
universe with closed timel curves that
would allow us to go backwards in time
did not Herman Bondi in 1957 at the
famous Chapel Hill conference talk about
the issue of negative mass and general
relativity i s say that he did and the
reason that he did was is that the
negative mass is still attracted to the
positive mass in the same way but the
positive mass is the one repelled the
two of them chase each other towards
unbounded acceleration that at least is
exciting sir stay in your chair George
George is it not true that you of all
people have to recognize that the
Einstein field equations are made from
from some pure geometry whereas the
energy conditions are brought in to keep
us from Madness to prop up what would
otherwise fall apart as a theory with
toothpicks and and and and masking tape
I submit to you sir that in fact the
entire thing is on very shaky ground and
you are trying to keep us in a pkin
village what say
[Laughter]
you I say if you could do it you would
be able to get Eternal motion going
you'd make your fortune you'd get your
Nobel Prize which is what really matters
to
physicist well but but my claim isn't
that this is possible but my claim is is
that when we do not allow ourselves to
go into the Adaptive Valley of Madness
we have no possibility of getting out
the other side at a higher level if had
dur stopped with numbers where a * B was
equal to negative B * a there aren't
numbers that do that and if he'd stopped
there we wouldn't have the direct
equation but he later realized that that
it had to be matrices so my question
isn't that what we are saying here makes
sense but that we have to enter some
kind of a state where we suspend the
very strong structures on reason and and
logic and consistency that you would
have us uh you would impose upon us so
that we may discover what this is
actually meant to be I I want to respond
to Eric wanting us to open our minds to
all possibilities and again I'm going to
go to an economic analogy and I've
talked about if the energy density plus
the pressure is negative all sorts of
things go wrong the economic analogy is
I can run a simulation on a computer
where the interest rate is negative and
the more money I put in the more money I
make money comes out of nowhere and
that's an exact analogy just the way the
gecko climbs the wall using the Casmir
effect with negative pressure and
negative negative energy so do negative
interest rates actually occur and we
have things like GIF and goods and I put
it to you sir that we consider those
things inside of economics
it's time to let different voices uh be
as irresponsible as the other voices
remember irresponsibility is the
Hallmark of great science it is a
byproduct Watson and Crick and Pauling
both came up with the triple helix with
the sugar phosphate Backbone in the
inside before Watson and Crick figured
it was a double helix with it with it on
the outside you have to let people be
wrong you have to let people dream and
you cannot keep shutting people down uh
just because they've uh failed to do
something within the theory all of our
old people Fineman showed up at the 1957
uh conference under the pseudonym I
believe Mr
Smith uh quantum gravity was founded by
two anti-gravity uh benefactors named
Babson and banson nobody talks about
this modern quantum gravity is an
outgrowth of the anti-gravity movement
of the 50s you have to let people go to
esselin you have to let them lie in uh
sensory deprivation tanks take some
psychedelics talk some absolute Madness
and stop pretending that we're so
respectable and you can't let one
Community dominate everything it's time
to party rock and roll have a great time
be much more irresponsible and try to
generate new ideas rather than recycling
the same seven ideas like wormholes that
we've been discussing to death to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas